well at this point you don't need to be
an avid Court Watcher to know that the
right of self-defense one of the most
fundamental rights that exists has
effectively been suspended in major
cities across this country the cases of
Kyle Rittenhouse the mosis George
Zimmerman Daniel Penny George Allen
Kelly Jose Alba Daniel Perry and so on
all make it clear that defending
yourself generally means that the
government will try to destroy your life
and sometimes succeed at the behest of
wealthy foreigners billionaires like
George Soros who don't live anywhere
near the Carnage they're inflicting on
American cities prosecutors now seek to
make an example out of anybody who takes
action to defend their life or property
and they have the full support of Joe
Biden's doj as they do it this is the
reality of living in any jurisdiction
controlled by leftists who can easily
select sympathetic jurries and secure a
conviction defend yourself and you'll be
accused of breaking the law most people
are aware of that now what most people
probably don't know is that
conservatives are now helping the left
neutralize the right of South defense
but yesterday's ruling by the US Supreme
Court is proof that's exactly what's
happening it's undeniable by a 5 to4
vote with two supposedly quote unquote
conservative justices in the majority
the Supreme Court gave the Biden
Administration the green light to
terminate the right of self-defense
along the southern border with Mexico
and this ruling is maybe the single most
significant attack on your right to
defend yourself and your property that
we've seen in at least a decade and it's
happening because of the quote unquote
conservative majority on the Supreme
Court that were supposed to be so so
grateful for so here's the upshot of the
ruling Supreme Court allowed the bid
Administration to remove razor wire
fencing placed by the state of Texas on
private property with the consent of
private property owners in order to keep
hundreds of thousands of illegal
migrants from flooding across the border
every single month so to restate the
Supreme Court is letting the border
patrol destroy border fencing set up by
Texas this is the kind of ruling that's
so incompatible with the fundamental
principle of self-defense and
self-determination and Common Sense and
not to mention n not to mention National
sovereignty that it defies explanation
really and appropriately enough the
Supreme Court did not provide an
explanation there was no majority
opinion explaining their reasoning here
but if you look at the docket from the
lower courts it's not hard to see what
might have convinced the justices in one
filing the B Administration solicitor
general argued that the razor wire
fencing endangered the lives of um of of
criminals who are swimming in the water
and trying to sneak into this country if
you have the fencing there it's going to
endanger their lives so here's what the
solicitor general Elizabeth prediger
told the court she said that the fening
prevents Agents from quote accessing or
getting near the border along the 2.5
Mile Stretch of the river and therefore
effectively prevented Agents from
monitoring the border to determine
whether a migrant requires emergency
aid now what was left unexplained in the
solicitor General's filing is why anyone
in the US has any obligation to provide
emergency Aid to foreign criminals who
are trying to invade this country
illegally you're not going to find that
requirement in the Constitution or in
any federal or state law it's just
invented out of thin air we are now
responsible for making sure that
Mexicans and Haitians and Guatemalans
get top-notch medical care as they swim
across the Rio Grand apparently which is
to say it is our responsibility to
provide medical care to noncitizens who
are injured while in the process of
attempting to break our
laws but if it's anyone's responsibility
why isn't it mexic meos or Hades or
Guatemala why don't we simply tell them
to take care of their own people there's
an
idea and what are they going to say well
we can't that's not practical we can't
do it oh but it's practical for
us now these are all good questions that
the Supreme Court decided are irrelevant
somehow now it goes without saying that
this is the inverse of the right of
self-defense the Biden Administration
and now the Supreme Court is saying that
you don't have the right to protect
yourself from foreign criminals
instead you have an obligation to
protect these foreign criminals from
themselves it's obscene but obviously
Joe Biden solicitor general doesn't mean
anything she's saying it's been clear
for months now that the Biden
Administration wants to tear down the
razor wire fencing so that it can import
as many foreigners into this country as
possible this is not about Emergency
Medical Aid back in October the outlet
border Hawk uh captured live footage of
federal border patrol agents using heavy
machinery to lift the r wire fencing
installed by Texas authorities at Eagle
Pass Texas so that hundreds of migrants
could stream across now watch this
footage and you will notice a distinct
absence of illegal aliens in need of
quote unquote emergency aid
watch Frank Gonzalez correspondent with
but hack news these are exclusive
imagins of how M Crossings of hundreds
of migrants have been carried out in
recent days at eal pass raising the bar
wire with machinery this huge Caravan of
around 300 migrants crossed into Eagle
Pass thanks to border patrol agents
lifting the barb wire the hundreds of
migrants cross it in a few minutes this
being the four massive Crossing that our
cameras witnessed in the last days of
October previously these Caravans are
sent to uninhabited areas of the Rio
Grande where border patrol a them with
forlift tractors given these facilities
migrants say they prefer to cross the
river instead of processing legal
[Music]
entry somehow these large groups of
migrants are informed about the place
and time when the forklifts raise the
barb wire to cross in
[Music]
drops and uh what you didn't hear there
if you're listening to the audio podcast
uh he was asked to two of the illegal
immigrants you know if they would rather
just come in Legally and go through the
legal process or cross the river and
they both say well they want to cross
the river because it takes too long to
do it
legally and this is an argument that
apparently we find compelling but it
takes them too long they don't feel like
waiting around so we'll just we'll just
send in heavy machinery to lift the
Border fence for
them the only thing missing there was
the was an actual red carpet being laid
out for them are you a few years or
decades out of school and wondering what
the heck did I even learn and what was
the point you might even be thinking I
don't have the time to learn something
new well if that's you you're not alone
and it's not too late Hillsdale College
is offering more than 40 free online
courses learn about the works of CS
Lewis the rise and fall of the Roman
Republic or the history of the ancient
Christian church with Hillsdale colleges
online courses if you're not sure where
to start check out American citizenship
citizenship and its decline with Victor
Davis Hansen in this eight lecture
course Victor explores the history of of
citizenship in the west and the threats
it faces today threats like the erosion
of the middle class The Disappearance of
our borders the growth of an
unaccountable deep State and the rise of
globalist
organizations this course is self-paced
so that you can start wherever and
whenever you want start your free course
of American citizenship and its decline
with Victor Davis Hansen today go to
hillsdale.edu Walsh to enroll there's no
cost it's easy to get started that's
hillsdale.edu Walsh to enroll
hillsdale.edu
Walsh now as the reporter with border HW
notes quote somehow these large groups
of migrants are informed about the place
in time when the forklifts raise the B
Bar wire to cross in
groups it's almost like the solicitor
general was lying but we all knew that
we all know the B Administration wants
to destroy the razor wire for the same
reason it sued Arizona for building a
makeshift wall out of shipping
containers along the border they want to
transform the population they want to
lead all these people into the country
with fake Asylum claims give them court
dates 10 years in the future and forget
all about them that's obvious what's
less clear by contract is why Amy Coney
Barrett and John Roberts two justices
who were once we were once told were
conservative would go along with this
fraud now right the at the outset it's
important to clarify that this case is
still making its way through the court
system on February 7th the fifth Circuit
Court of Appeals based in New Orleans is
going to hear arguments on the issue of
whether the bid Administration has the
legal authority to cut Razer wire along
the southern border so this is still a
live issue what happened is that before
it heard those arguments the fifth
circuit entered a temporary injunction
prohibiting the B ation from cutting any
more wire while the case was proceeding
the B Administration filed an emergency
appeal of that injunction because they
really want to cut the wire as quickly
as possible and get all these immigrants
uh I.E future voters into the country
and the Supreme Court in a 5 to4 vote
lifted the injunction and allowed the
fence cutting to continue so basically
Supreme Court is saying yeah just keep
cutting the fences until we figure out
whether it's legal for you to do that or
not now three of those five votes were
always in the bag for the B
Administration that's because unlike
Republicans Democrats know how to
appoint justices to the Supreme Court
who will Faithfully carry out the
objectives of their party but
Republicans are incapable of doing that
so John Roberts and Amy Cony Barrett who
we were told was a major win for
conservatives when Trump appointed her
you know we're still told that this is a
grand achievement of Trump's
Administration was the these three
justices um even though only one has
proven to be somewhat Dependable um but
they voted with koni brown Jackson Sonia
s mayor and Elena Kagan now we all know
why John Roberts would do that he's
openly admitted that he's preoccupied
with making sure the court appears
nonpartisan rather than applying the law
and um but why would Amy Cony Barrett
join the leftist judges now whatever the
explanation and I'll get into that in a
moment I have one Theory as to why that
might be but this is becoming something
of a pattern an analysis by the
Washington examiner found that in 2020
and 2021 Barrett voted similarly with
liberal justices in just over half of
the cases heard
and she's continued to side with them uh
ever since last year for example Barrett
and John Roberts sided with the Court's
leftists to ban the sale of so-called
ghost guns which is an invented term
that's intended to criminalize the
transportation of firearm parts and just
a few weeks ago Barrett rejected a a
challenge to Illinois's ban on so-called
assault weapons which is a category of
firearms that also doesn't actually
exist and she also blocked a challenge
to Indiana University's requirement that
all students and employees take the
covid shot and as Daniel Horwitz pointed
out during Co Barrett had no problem
with the state of Illinois locking down
its own citizens she indicated that
under the Constitutional police power
states can close businesses and schools
to protect Public Health what's odd
about Amy con Barrett's reasoning is
that it apparently doesn't apply to the
state of Texas or any citizens living
there they don't have a right to invoke
the police power to prevent foreigners
from streaming across the border
according to Amy con Barrett even though
many of those ille illegal immigrants do
have communic I able
diseases this isn't a an invented
concern it's very real you can go to
pretty much any hospital near the border
and you will see that they are
completely
overwhelmed here for example is the Yuma
Regional Medical uh Center look at
this I'm Dr Robert trench I'm the
president and CEO and I've been here for
7 and a half years we have a 406 bed
hospital we've had a significant number
across the border um when it was
announced that the borders were open
um and we've had a multitude of patients
uh come to our doors and needing medical
care we're the only hospital here so
it's not like we can distribute to uh to
other hospitals in the area we're the
closest hospital that does what we do is
180 miles away so the hospital's been
impacted greatly because none of the
migrants have a payer source and that's
our biggest issue they've come to our
doors and we give them the same level of
care we'd give any body else if
President Biden walked through the door
or if a migrant walks through the door
they're getting the same level of care
we don't treat anybody any differently
and we take a lot of pride in that our
concern is that we've had we've
delivered over $20 million in
uncompensated care to these individuals
just over a six-month period you know
that's an unsustainable model to have
that unexpected expense without any
Revenue to offset it this is a hospital
that was set up for the benefit of
American citizens and because the
bitamin ministration is deliberately
flooding this nation with diseased
foreigners it may have to shut down and
it's losing millions of dollars and if
it does shut down obviously that would
impact the public health in Yuma but the
conservative swing votes on the Supreme
Court don't care apparently it's only
American citizens who have to endure
quarantines and lockdowns in the name of
Public Health this isn't just happening
in Border towns by the way hospitals in
large cities like New York which of
course is nowhere near the border are
also overwhelmed by The Surge of
migrants watch we're back now with the
record record number of migrants
Crossing into the US pushing resources
to the limit in many American cities now
hospitals are sounding the alarm saying
they're also overwhelmed including some
far from the border Julia anley has our
report tonight the Border crisis surging
officials telling NBC News there were
over 200,000 illegal Crossings at the
southern border last month and a record
3 million migrants crossed the border in
the last year now a new warning a th000
miles away in New York City where
officials tell us resources are
overwhelmed across public hospitals in
New York City over the last year nearly
30,000 visits by migrants and 300 new
babies born to migrant moms staff here
at Belleview Hospital tell us they're
eager to help but the numbers are tough
this has been the hardest work that I've
ever done but it's been the most
impactful work that I've ever done and
most of the visits to the taxpayer
funded Legal Clinic here are by migrants
our clinics are full and there are
waiting lists and people are turning
people away or referring them to other
places so these are hospitals in the
largest cities of the United States
which is thousands of miles from the
southern border and they can't handle
all of these illegal migrants how is
this not considered a massive threat to
Public Health exactly where are all the
schools of Public Health that lectured
us about the importance of wearing
masks worshiping George Floyd and
forcing our children to look at iPads
all day they're all silent strangely
enough
again so is Amy con Barrett who
supposedly cared a lot about public
health just a few years
ago it's not clear what explains the way
Amy con Barrett is voting um one
possibility is that she believes that
the constitution gives total authority
to the executive branch to handle
immigration matters to the point where
the federal government can totally
ignore immigration and Asylum laws
passed by Congress and import millions
of illegal aliens without any vetting
whatsoever that seems dubious which is
probably why four conservative justices
didn't go along with that reason another
possibility is that uh it's not a
coincidence that all of the women on the
court plus Roberts who is close enough
cided against Texas's border wall the
argument against border enforcement has
always been a purely emotional one but
so maybe it's not a surprise that the
all the women on the court you know are
find the emotional argument to be more
compelling than most of the men do but
being Guided by emotions is one thing
and it's bad enough for Supreme Court
Justices the problem is that one of the
big problems is that all of the sympathy
you know all of the sympathetic emotions
are being directed towards the illegal
immigrants and no sympathy is being
directed towards the American families
that this invasion is destroying and
that's odd because at this point the
federal government isn't just failing to
defend our border and uphold our
sovereignty they're taking active steps
to ensure that we have no borders at all
and no sovereignty and very soon our
critical infrastructure will fail
because of it it's often said that
civilizational decline is a
choice and that's true and we've never
seen a clearer case of it than this
there's just no other way to spin the
story when the bid Administration is
literally going to court to get
permission to destroy border fencing
without a border you don't have a
country one of the most basic
responsibilities of the government is to
ensure that we have a border and we
enforce our laws and our government is
not doing that anymore
in fact they are doing the opposite they
are actively doing the opposite this is
not we we've moved Beyond just mere
negligence okay which is which is the
failure to enforce the border now
they're actively preventing anyone from
enforcing
it if this continues the solution is
obvious which is that red State
Governors will need to ignore the
Supreme Court and do what needs to be
done to protect their citizens and the
Border all of these rules that have
sustain this country for so long can be
broken I mean we've seen that they all
operate in the end on a sort of mutual
agreement I mean you you proceed through
traffic lights when they're green on the
assumption that everyone perpendicular
to you is going to stop on red but once
people start going through the Reds in
large numbers you have no reason to pay
any attention to your own traffic light
everyone's on their own at that point
but once one side decides that law and
Border no longer matter then everybody
else is released from their obligations
to obey the federal court system I mean
you can't obey it
anymore to obey it is to is to usher in
your own
destruction that's what happens it's
happened before in this country's
history and uh it's it can happen
again and you know the thing is the
Supreme Court can't enforce its own Ru
rulings so once red States decide not to
go along with them if the red States say
okay I don't care what you think we're
going to do it anyway what happens then
what happens when federal agents try to
destroy border fencing and state
troopers stand in their way does Biden
send in the military at that
point these might not be hypothetical
questions for long the last Civil War
was
unimaginable until it wasn't that was a
lesson this country learned in the
middle of the 19th century and if the
Biden Administration is somehow still in
office after this next election then
just as abruptly we might have to learn
it again if You' like to see what else I
have to say you can access my full show
by going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to
see you there Godspeed